this video is sponsored by Squarespace
Dragon Ball super had a rough ride
between recapping the films and its
animation melting before our eyes while
I was watching I was almost certain the
show would get cancelled at the earliest
convenience but it didn't and that's
when an idea hit me what if I found all
the Japanese TV ratings for the show and
cross-referenced them with Google Trends
data and user scores on IMDB to find the
episodes that had the biggest impact in
Dragon Ball super success I mean it
sounds like a good idea and so to cut a
long story short I found the ratings and
made the graph mapping Dragon Ball super
ratings from start to finish and there's
some surprises in there for sure
but in order to get the most accurate
idea of which episodes were the most
successful I will be referencing three
graphs the first graph Maps the TV
ratings I just made the second is an
IMDB score graph that map's the scores
of every individual episode in the
series and the third maps the Google
Trends of how the show performed during
its time on the air and so using this
empirical data I want to take you on a
journey to find out together what were
the episodes that saved Dragon Ball
super
ok so let me break down how this is
gonna work I have three graphs a TV
ratings graph an IMDB user score graph
and a Google Trends graph each of these
assigned some rating that accompanies a
given episode I am going to combine the
three scores I give an episode receives
to establish what I am calling a
popularity score and so whichever
episode has the biggest popularity score
at the end wins for example let's take a
look at one of the worst performing
episodes episode 5 the episode received
a 5.3 TV rating a 6.5 IMDB score and a
2.9 Coogler trend score giving it a
popularity score of 14 point 7 and with
that explained let's start at the
beginning the show kicks off with a bang
due to the initial hype and expectations
the episode scores high across the board
the Japanese TV ratings are at a seven
point nine the episode reviews very well
in IMDB with a seven point four and the
Google trends are substantial also
making this a very well-rounded and very
well-received episode resulting in a
popularity score of nineteen point nine
however as you can probably see
disappointment quickly sets in by
episode two the TV ratings nosedive and
trending on Google drastically decreases
resulting in a popularity score of
sixteen point would not terrible but the
fatigue of recapping battle of gods is
telling as by episode 12 the one where
bears and Goku clash fists for 20
minutes the show received the lowest
rating thus far on Japanese TV the
episode received a 4.7 it's Google trend
impact had more than halved since
episode 1 and despite it reviewing well
and IMDB it only managed a popularity
score of thirteen point eight not
exactly the stellar comeback many were
expecting from one of the most popular
animes in history around this time I was
almost certain the show would get
canceled the battle of gods arc didn't
exactly set the world on fire and
resurrection F was primed to continue
that downward trend during this time the
anime was showing signs of having an
abhorrent production schedule resulting
in animation like this
in addition to the ratings and all of
this the show suffered on a story front
also the manga was ahead of the anime
and it was already covering new material
however that would soon come to an end
on February 21st 2016 Dragon Ball super
Zanna may overtook the manga for the
very first time resulting in the highest
TV rating the show received since
episode 1 a 7.3 accompanied by a small
uptick in Google Trends and a favorable
IMDB score the episode garnered a 17.3
popularity score and while the ratings
would again dip they for the most part
held higher than the prior two arcs that
is until this happened receiving a
television rating of 7.2 trending with
Google at four point one and embracing
the highest IMDB rating an individual
episode received thus far with a score
of eight point two nine of Dragon Ball
super soared to the top of everyone's
favorite super episode lists this moment
proved that Dragon Ball super could
deliver moments that could compete with
Dragon Ball Z and more importantly gave
Dragon Ball super some much-needed
positive publicity after how the media
across the world lambasted it for its
animation the universe six arc finished
shortly after an overall left pans with
a much more optimistic outlook for the
future of the series with a stronger TV
rating performance and believe you me we
thought it could only get better from
here
Dragon Ball super 47th episodes shocked
the world after strong promotion for
this arc with teasers and interviews
with akira toriyama episode 47 claimed
the highest TV rating the series had
ever received and would ever receive by
far with an 8.4 in addition to reviewing
well in IMDB and creating buzz online as
represented by Google Trends the episode
garnered a fantastic popularity score of
19 point 8 and yes while that popularity
rating was still slightly lower than the
all-time high set by episode 1 the show
had clearly reached a new standard and
was well on its way to surpassing that
average popularity score with
installments like episode 50 performing
very well compared with the rest of the
series the animation schedule while
still incredibly tough on the production
staff was no longer showing the signs of
collapse that prior acts were so
prominently demonstrated culminating in
episode 66 the Big Finish for the arc
despite showing signs of viewer fatigue
with a somewhat mediocre TV rating of 6
point 6 it also enjoyed a massive IMDB
score of eight point two tied with
episode 39 in being the highest rated
individual episode on the entire series
thus far
the Goku black arc reignited a fire
within the fandom and with having
claimed the highest TV rating this
series had enjoyed as well as time the
highest IMDB user rating it surely was
only a matter of time before a new high
popularity score would be made now this
is typically where I would have skipped
ahead to the universe survival arc but
during the filler portion of the series
that followed the Future Trunks arc
something no one saw coming happened
they popped a really high rating a seven
point six to help put that into
perspective that is a higher rating than
all of Resurrection F and universe 6
it's a rating so high only two other
episodes beated in the entire series
episode 1 which barely counts and
episode 47 this episode received a high
rating that episode 39 and 66 the widely
praised climaxes of the prior two arcs
and the episode that achieved that
rating was this one
this episode centered around krillin and
Goku's training was a major nostalgic
throwback for a multitude of reasons it
kicked things off with a fight between
goku and gohan followed it up with
another fight between goku and krillen
and featured characters that otherwise
wouldn't have had a prominent role in
the series like a teen and Master Roshi
however it is important to note that
during this week ratings across the
board were up significantly so its
success could be for a multitude of
reasons however to this day this
episode's action and emotional segments
cement it as one of my personal
favorites and I'm happy to see others
enjoyed it too following these events
the universe survival r came into full
swing with an all-new opening theme song
and animation it was clear that toy was
going all-out for this particular arc
episodes like 80 95 and 100 while not
performing as strongly as expected in
the TV ratings department they
outperformed the vast majority of the
series in terms of IMDB score and Google
Trends data resulting in some solid
popularity scores to help put this in
perspective the universe Survival Act
reviewed so well that if you were to
rank the top 20 best rated episodes in
Dragon Ball super on IMDB the universe
survival arc would account for 18 of the
top 20 spots on the list with only
episodes thirty nine and sixty-six
edging their way in but for whatever
reason ratings across the board were
down during this time period and it
wasn't just for Dragon Ball super every
other show including one piece was down
considerably resulting in some of the
lowest ratings this series had ever
received consistently and looking at
these ratings you would think that most
people would no longer be watching or
even care about Dragon Ball however
nothing could be further from the truth
despite poor ratings in Japan the
stellar reviews at IMDB and the enormous
social media activity across the world
including Japan surrounding the final
episodes was nothing short of astounding
with the final episode 131 achieving the
highest IMDB rating in the series
history with an impressive 8.7 and the
second-highest Google trend score of 7.5
creating an enormous popularity score of
21.9 Dragon Ball super very much
finished on a high but the series finale
wasn't the biggest difference maker
it almost was but one other episode or
should I say special beat it by a hair
what I think is particularly interesting
about this special is that while it was
hugely successful everywhere else it
also provided Dragon Ball super with the
lowest rating this series ever saw on TV
with a meager 3.5 this was by no means a
reflection of the episodes quality but
more so a reflection of toys poor
timeslot selection while Dragon Ball
super aired during this time Super
Sentai and Kamen Rider aired in their
new time slots alongside one another
these are all toy animation shows which
resulted in all of their ratings tanking
as viewership was divided between the
various properties however more than
anything else I think this serves to
prove a point the age of television is
quite evidently coming to an end while
Dragonball Z was on the air shows across
the board had more than four times the
viewership they have now people are
clearly moving to different platforms to
watch their favorite shows for instance
while Dragon Ball super was on the air
it was one of if not the highest
streamed show on crunchyroll and as
Dragon Ball super popular tease seemed
to wane on TV its skyrocketed online as
seen on DS Google Trends and do you see
that massive spike that was Dragon Ball
super 's television special and the
quote lowest TV rated episode in the
show's history it was so popular it
crashed crunchyroll servers as thousands
of people flooded to watch Dragon Ball
super so now that you're off to date
with the ratings this is where things
get really interesting it's time to find
out which of these five options you
thought was the most important part of
Dragon Ball super success cast your vote
right now
was it episode 39 47 66 131 or this
special I'm excited to find out which of
these you thought was the most important
and if your favorite episode wasn't on
this list leave a comment down below and
I'll be sure to read it crunching the
numbers at all of this was extremely fun
interesting and I hope you enjoyed going
down the rabbit hole of Dragon Ball
super the episodes that saved a series I
want to take a moment to thank the
sponsor of today's video Squarespace
Squarespace is an online website
creation service that provides you with
the tools to create clean impressive and
professional websites with ease if you
need somewhere to host your artwork want
to start a blog or need an online store
build that website with Squarespace they
have a plethora of professional and
stylish design templates for you to
choose from and if you need comment
management systems their mobile app has
you covered they really are the one-stop
shop when it comes to starting your own
website and the best part you can start
your free trial at squarespace.com and
if you use the offer code totally not
mark you can get 10% off your first
purchase
happy website building and I'll see you
all next week
[Music]